do you wanna help with Hurricane relief efforts
and also have a chance to go see the Taylor Swift Aeros tour
I'm working with my friend Chloe
who I'm gonna tag down below
who was graciously anonymously
gifted these two Aeros tour tickets for the New Orleans show on October 26th
the donor wants to remain anonymous
but is a 25 year resident of Texas
who has been personally impacted by hurricanes
and wanted to do something to help with relief efforts
so we're raffling off these two tickets
I will have the link in my bio
the winner will be drawn on October 20th at twelve PM Central Standard Time
over on Chloe's page again
she'll be tagged down below
and every single raffle entry gets you closer to possibly winning these
errors tour tickets these are approximately the view from your seats
I know a lot of us have been feeling really helpless
with how to help these communities
and this is just one way that we can kind of band together
and use the goodness of someone else's hearts
to help these communities out in their time of need
so I'm gonna have the link to the raffle in my linktree
in my link in my bio I'm gonna send you over to Chloe's page
she also is gonna have that
enter as many times as you want
every single entry is uh
as donation to a relief effort and an entry into the Aeros Tour raffle
the raffle is gonna be pulled on a live stream on Chloe's page
not mine on Chloe's page
twelve PM Central Standard Time on October 20th
for the October 26th New Orleans Aeros Tour show
good luck everybody and prayers
to everybody who's been affected by Hurricane Helen and Hurricane Milton
I hope this is some way that we can all come together to help